Mini 6-jährige Tochter hat sich
aufgesetzt sie bräuchtet der ist der
Gedanke bei ihrem Kopf sie und sie hat
am Schluss völlig verzweifelt
und der Seite du brauchst das Internet
philosophische Intervention gemacht
ja nein
[Musik]
heute haben wir das Fleisch und Bossard
über Black Friday über Konsum und über
Verzicht black
Fridays mit diskutieren
und da heißt tatsächlich
wähle den Kaufladen aber wegen besonders
ich mir vier Prozent sparst
durchschnittlich also die Brise werden
die
ursprungs-gedanken
so ich muss immer so lachen
der Schweiz
gehabt Frauen
und eigentlich passt zu mir aber es
konnte gar nicht darum passt oder nicht
sondern dass er sie eigentlich
damit die anderen
genau
oder sehr schön
die Tempel dass das quasi religiöse
ersatzt Konsum ist so eine Riesending
erhöht das ist ja wie irgendwie Wasser
für Fisch mit Sense gar nicht so absurd
was mir da alles kein konsumieren
interessant finde
also ich brauche eine Matratze und
kaufen Matratze ich brauche ein bisschen
Brot und das Produkt kaufen
und will einfach die ganze
Nahrungsmittel und und Grundprodukt sage
ich jetzt mal gar nicht so teuer
hätten wir quasi nur viel mehr Produkte
erfunden wo man gar nicht brauchen und
bitte funktioniert aber stille von
Bedürfnis gar nicht so gut will doch
auch schon zum Beispiel vielleicht auch
eine Jacke nicht wie du geboren
am laufen ja und was kaufen wir
überhaupt und was
Patagonia zum Beispiel
Patagonia hätte das schöne Satz Brett
kauft diese Jacke nicht Kauf nur was du
wirklich brauchst und das hat die
perfekte Form von alle aufgeladen
nachhaltig leben
verkauft oder du bist eine bessere
Mensch Jacke und so funktioniert's halt
oder und viel Bedürfnis werdet einfach
geschaffen also was sind schon alleine
Bedürfnis wenn man Aufsätze und schlafen
und dann besessen fertig so bitte
Philosoph von Kapitalismus und bestätigt
von Konsum und rett von
inszenierungswert oder wahres gebraucht
werden
und tatsächlich ist die
inszenierungswert heute Produkt wie man
so viele Sachen gar nicht brauchen
auffällig ich finde das zum Teil sehr
schön ich weiß nicht Minimalismus
weniger Zeit verbringen wie museumshop
Willi Museums-Shop kannst du kaufen dass
du die Ausstellung
mit
Katalog
oder magnetschrank und irgendwie die
Vorstellung dass das wohl nichts gesehen
hat das wird die konsumiere nicht nur
sondern auch konsumieren genau
nur das Konzert sondern du wolltest noch
erst schlafensgefühl und Identität du
bist aber FCZ-Fan und hast du schon wo
das zeigt wo dich leben das ist
interessant und das mit vielen Marken so
was
ich bin
loslassen warum
der Singularitäten also die Idee dass
man sich quasi wird abheben von den
anderen vom Einheitspreis
also ich habe die und die Jacke die und
die Turnschuhe der Rucksack den Curry
zur Gruppe sowieso und blickt immer denn
wieder singuläre also ich finde das im
Moment extrem gut zeigen mit dem Revival
von der adidas Trainer Wasser
fehl Jugendliche haben zu einer Hose und
du musst die Hose haben es muss da die
das Training aber bitte in Erfahrung
also einerseits dazu gehören zum quasi
Identität zur Gruppe aber auch
Singularität ich habe Kombination wo
niemand und Wehe meine Kollegin hätten
die gleiche Gefahren
Black Friday sind Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter von Amazon und die
protestieren
mit
Produktionsbedingungen
wieder neue Kleiderkollektionen
produzieren wie verrückt also das ist
interessant aber
das finde ich so lustig will ich meine
wie viel Tage
[Gelächter]
betroffen genau
CO2 Emissionen kompensiert aber es geht
dann eigentlich visusst viel
Geld es ist schon immer eine
Frage was ist wirklich nachhaltiger gibt
es nachhaltiger Konsum genau
Punkt all die Produkte wo jetzt
große Welt verbessern wenn das kauft ich
eigentlich ein Stück Ideologie also es
ist falsches Bewusstsein überzeugt wird
wie das ist nicht so dann ist es doch so
schön gesagt ich besitze nicht dann
werde ich nicht besessen und das finde
ich finde die hätte bis extrem Wurst
oder
[Musik]
und sie hat am Schluss völlig
verzweifelt
die ganze Gesellschaft wieder erkennt
die Dinge da wird irgendeinen einfachen
Gedanken in der Pflanzen und der Seite
du brauchst das Internet
philosophische Intervention gemacht
ja nein
die ganze Geschichte erzählt und so und
was ist das eigentlich hätte also
aktivieren und das ist ja für mich
extrem wichtiger Punkt
muss man ja nicht viel kaufen das
erinnert mich immer daran
immer im
herbstanz
und hat aufgeschrieben was man braucht
Barbara zwei Paar Strumpfhose ein Rock
ein Hose leider kein Problem
und das
gestanden ist und hört man jetzt statt
Mongolei
interessant das ist schon vielen anderen
Welt
ich finde es ja schön nein es ist schon
okay
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
zum Thema Minimalismus und das Gespräch
bedeutet und wenn du mir vielleicht
doch der Kanal danke